da liegt ein toter mensch in unserem
haus
wie kommt er denn hier rein war was hast
du getan
ich war's nicht erzähl mir was passiert
ist k s habe ich noch nie in meinem
leben gesehen hast du diese personen
umgebracht k s bitte keine leute ich das
würde ich nie im leben total egal was du
gemacht hast kurz bevor ich nach hause
carla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla und ich habe ihm die
mit 30 mal in die brust gestochen habe
das tötet leute ich es ist mir selten
passiert war op nun ich habe sie gekocht
und gegangen allerdings wieder einmal
wann und willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wie schmeckt und heute testen wir wie
menschen schmecken aber warum steht an
der ecke werbevideo mache ich etwa
werbung für menschen vielleicht nein die
neue achte staffel geburt kommt am 23 10
also heute auf sky ticket entertainment
online es gibt nämlich wieder das
angebot für einen euro im monat könnt
ihr euch komplett alles von the walking
dead anschauen
alle 99 folgen die es bis jetzt gab also
alle sieben staffeln und die neue achte
staffel ab dem 13
und das wird die hundertste folge sein
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen jetzt
alles kommt auch in london die ganzen
letzten 99 folgen haben darauf
hingearbeitet das ist jetzt so richtig
es wird keine zombies töten und 18 das
ist strengsten untersagt wohl in der
sendung damit auch getötet eigentlich
dort dieses messer auf meinen corp ich
habe vorhin abgerissen auszusehen alter
rené bock habt jeden montag die neueste
folge von gebrauchten der zuschauer in
deutsch oder originalsprache link unten
auf den link meldet euch an es monatlich
kündbar also sichere sache hier und
jetzt gehts los mit dem baby und heute
kein richtiges rezept was ist in der
sehr
er wirkt sondern machen so coole walking
dead halloween snacks die man am
halloween anbieten kann oder auch auf
walking der tat macht ihr so war das
früher mit game of thrones gemacht
werden uns immer alles angeschaut
zusammenhalt getroffen und das immer so
schön zelebrieren das macht spaß also
was da auf einer guten party nicht
fehlen außer muffins natürlich suppe
aber wir machen nicht so eine normale
hier ist eine suppe so bleiben wir
wollen wir herausfinden wie menschen
schmecken was wir niemals tun werden
denn sonst sind wir kannibalen und dafür
kommt man in tripolis wir werden auf
jeden fall so eine suppe machen und so
tun als ob wir so viele menschen ist da
die suppe nicht nur wegen menschen essen
so ein brocken der charakter haben soll
besteht die hauptsächlich aus haben
werden die wird irgend einem
leerstehenden haus gefunden haben und
nicht im supermarkt unseres vertrauens
the walking dead brauchen wie ihr zu er
habe super viele freunde haben noch
unsere halloween-party super viele
menschen kommen werden brauchen wir
einen großen topf als ob ich dir somit
nicht alleine lassen würde
was machen wir so ist eigentlich meter
easy weil wir einfach alles zusammen
haben aber glaubt mir sehr gut schmecken
was für ein zufall ich habe tomaten
stücke gefunden zum glück kann man die
dosen so leicht ausmachen weil die leute
die mich kennen wissen dass ich kein
treffen mit den tomaten kommen jetzt in
den topf okay das war eine richtig dumme
idee megawatt eure dose auf ihr fahrrad
später war was für ein zufall ich habe
noch eine dose tomaten stücke gefunden
vorsichtig noch eine dose calais
als nächstes haben wir eine dose mais
gefunden hat kidney bohnen die mag ich
am allerliebsten was für ein glück ist
für sie gefunden haben
kidney bohnen joinen den meist tomaten
schöne weiße riesen boden gehören auch
immer an so eine suppe dazu weiße riesen
bohn heißen auf polnisch wir haben immer
zu
in polen gut gegessen und die weißen
riesen boden david mega eklig auch
deswegen brauchen wir unbedingt möhren
habe die eigentlich schon trocken wird
geschaut denn ja seid ihr auch so
gespannt auf die neue stoffe
ich hab echt lange darauf gewartet wie
schnecken dosen reichen ja ich glaube
ich könnte so eine apokalypse überleben
dosen und karotten briefing uns zu guter
letzt rehazentrum gut lief es super
ich habe mich irgendwie überleben würde
ich glaube ich könnte so eine apokalypse
überleben also das müssen wir jetzt mal
zusammen und sieht aus wie normales
essen ist jetzt wieder mit mir mit
mandanten
das muss nämlich jetzt auch unsere
feuerstelle das wird jetzt ganz
anstrengen das feuer an zu machen
ich hab s geschafft ich habe heuer
gebracht ob auch unsere feuerstelle und
jetzt erstmal alles warm werden wenn ich
dann irgendwann anfängt zu lockern
können wir weitermachen
lecker und jetzt war schon unser
konservendosen aus und machen dieses
papier so sie am ende oder
konservendosen aus wenn ihr sie aus
gespielt habt und das papier hat gemacht
habe und wofür wir sie später brauchen
das verrate ich euch jetzt noch nicht so
ganz
natürlich schmeckt die suppe jetzt noch
ein bisschen langweilig deswegen
gewürzen wie sie und dem einzigen mittel
mit dem ich eigentlich würze gemüsebrühe
jetzt alles gut verrühren und jetzt
probieren wir diese ultra heiße suppe
ein bisschen gemüsebrühe und nummer 3
und probieren heißt jeden fall klar
während die suppe weiter vor sich hin
köchelt machen jetzt etwas ganz
spezielles und dafür brauchen weder
würstchen die anfänger erinnern sollen
ist echt so trick 17 nach sind natürlich
vegetarische bürstchen aber ihr könnt
auch echte wie finger scheint es an ihr
zeigt euch mein mittel würstchen mein
gott war schlicht wir brauchen eine
handelsübliche farbe die auf unsere
feuerstelle und dann müssen wir wieder
feuer machen
insgesamt strebe seiten und so würstchen
vor dem braten ein bisschen vor und zwar
schneiden wir hier verordnet so ein
bisschen was aber ja eigentlich der
fingernagel ist und dann sitzen wir so
leichte rillen rein wie wir hier in den
fingern so haben wir das müssen
realistisch außen und dann mache ich
noch hinten so zwei grobe patzer rein
damit das so auseinander fällt aber ihr
werdet sehen beim braten ich hoffe das
klappt so wie es mir vorstelle und
schneidig ein bisschen sieht wirklich
aus wie so gleichen finger
das zieht richtig aus wie so ein
gleichen finger das machen wir jetzt mit
einem höheren und jetzt eure finger
häuschen in der pfanne braten und
während die würstchen fröhlich hinter
mir vor sich hin braten gehen wir einmal
wieder rüber und machen was ganz cool
für die suppe ist dafür brauche ich ein
stück rolf von dort machte daraus eine
kugel der rolfer die beste investition
meines lebens gewesen so das schöne
kugel draus machen
und vorher gut die hände waschen kleine
weiße kugel brauchen wie und das
brauchen wir doch einen pinsel und
unsere lebensmittel fahren wenn ihr
welche habt wenn nicht dann bleibt jetzt
werden wir kreativ mit unser
lebensmittelfarbe ich habe so ein
bisschen braun jetzt und malerei
braunen kreis so rainer kunz mit
schwarzer lebensmittelfarbe mache ich
jetzt einen punkt holt habt ihr schon
habt ihr ein auge jetzt richten wir
unsere super an und dafür brauchen wir
eine von diesen konservendose machen
nämlich da die suppe ein spoiler die mir
saßen die dose wird super heißt das
essen drin aber jetzt kommt das
wichtigste
jetzt nehmen es nämlich so eine
gebratene finger wurst in die suppe rein
ok und das sieht schon mal gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus das ist nämlich unser
finger ihr könnt noch einen finger
mangel basteln wir brauchen noch was
ganz wichtig für unseren finger auch
unseren finger machen wir natürlich noch
so einen manchen splitter bin hier ja
jetzt sieht das gut aus aber das
wichtigste fehlten auch da wir ja
menschen essen und auch ein auge so
obendrauf vor
geil hingesehen solange diese beweis
stellen wir uns jetzt wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
menschen suppe konservendosen so
wahrscheinlich was jeder student schon
weiß okay richtig gut ganz ehrlich mehr
braucht man nicht auf so einer party auf
der du schon stunden war es wenn da
jemand mal mit so einer suppe rumkommt
die ist in sekunden weg und jetzt der
finger okay das war eine sehr gute idee
da kritzeleien zu machen weil das sieht
vom namen für dich so widerlich aus und
dieser trick mit der mangel ne super
perfekt aber vanessa nach seiner
europartner fast süßes bekommen ein
problem dafür habe ich mir auch ein ganz
tolles rezept ausgelagert eine halloween
party ist machen wir natürlich noch
machen was da auf jeden
geburtstagspartys partys partys nicht
fehlen machte sich liebe machen sie habe
ich vorhin vorbereitet warnt bei nicht
schmeckt schon so oft muffins gemacht
habe und guckt euch die anderen videos
an wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man muffins
machen sind der renner video bei wie
schmidt deutschland hab ich schon
muffins gemacht hier habe ich zu dem
grundrezept auch eine rote
lebensmittelfarbe gepackt heute hier
wird unglaublich besser aber so einfach
gute machen sind ja langweilig
ja immer noch in walking der thema also
was brauchen wir um die muffins zu
gestalten natürlich unter creme mit
unser allseits beliebten buttercreme
fertigmischung habe schon diese
grundmasse erstellt und muss da jetzt
noch 160 70 80 gramm butter hinzufügen
und dann machen wir leckere bitte
einfach wie butter hinzufügen zombie
apokalypse und sowie im bilde nutzen ein
handrührgerät da ist er wieder der
starke abend jetzt rührt er so lange bis
es eine buttercreme geworden ist eine
rose oder creme brauche mache ich jetzt
ein bisschen rosa rein eine gute spitze
und jetzt schaut mal was mit der
buttercreme passiert
ich habe definitiv zu weben ok diese
gruselige rosa buttercreme muss jetzt in
einen spritzbeutel spritzbeutel wollte
hier haben wir eine wiederverwendbare
spritzbeutel mit unserer mutter creme
bestreichen wir uns in muffins und nicht
so ganz normal sondern machen kleine
gehirne drau tutorial von vanessa wie
macht man gegen dafür zusammen und erst
drachen wir random ein bisschen kriegen
so dann streichen wir die creme nicht
aus wie kaugummi ein streit in der mit
jetzt so weit dass sie trete ich wieder
aus und das macht jetzt mit aller die
gehirnmasse sind wirklich besser
geworden hat sich es erwartet habe das
sieht wirklich super widerlich wie so
kleine gehirne die da oben drauf so
gehirne aber das sei einer der kann man
die walking der deswegen brauchen wir
noch einen baseballschläger was häufig
sieht nicht so ganz aus wie im baseball
schläger befand dass die müssen wir noch
braun anmalen das ist hier nämlich ein
baseballschläger und die liebe
wochenwert schon geschaut haben das ist
doch jetzt ganz bestimmt was das für ein
baseballschläger warstein beispiel
schläger sein soll sei derzeit wohl aus
dem baseballschläger oder der kommt
jetzt so obendrauf gehirn reingepackt
nehme jetzt noch rote lebensmittelfarbe
und mal noch so um den baseball
das sieht ja so schön der baseball
schläger könnte ein bisschen kleiner
vielleicht sein aber ihr wisst was
gemeint ist und nach dieser kassel
die finger so bestellen wir uns erneut
die frage wie schmeckt menschenfleisch
beziehungsweise ein muffin der aussieht
wie ein gehirn auf dem mit einem
baseball-schläger drauf gehauen wurde
[Musik]
schmeckt wie immer gut
also macht uns habe ich mittlerweile
genug gemacht möglich man könnte auch
apple marmelade demnach hat man etwas
fruchtiges da war sehr sehr lecker beide
gerichte sind super coole party snacks
die suppe geht mega schnell also das
sind ja nur ein paar konservendosen die
man zusammen gemixt hat der mann der
dort ein bisschen länger also da muss
man dann diese buttercreme machen und in
machen und dann diese dinger form aber
wenn man kreatives und ein bisschen lust
drauf hat dann ist das auch sehr sehr
spaßig wie immer hoffe ich natürlich
dass euch das video gefallen hat und
wenn ihr mit einem daumen nach oben mein
gott kann ich schon schnell sagen und
teilt das video mit euren freunden
vielleicht mit jemanden werden halloween
party macht und wenn jetzt lust bekommen
auf die neue staffel gewonnen der
zuschauen oder die ganzen anderen
folgendes wenigen dann klickt auf den
ersten link in der infobox dort kommt
ihr nämlich zum sky ticket
entertainment-angebot und da könnt ihr
für 1 euro monatlich in einem monat im
ersten monat könnt ihr die gucken ist
dass sie teure für 1 euro komplett
geleert müsst ihr schnell sein bis jeden
tag ein paar folgen gucken so ist das
manchmal im leben ist nicht immer
pustekuchen wunschkonzert ich hab mein
gehört verloren dann leute kann ich mich
auch mal ordentlich verabschieden
ich freue mich dass ihr euch das video
bis hierhin angeschaut habt ihr seid
wirklich stark mit euren nerven und bis
dann